the batman is finally here but what's up
with those twin bouncers and what's
going on with selena and her friend from
the photo who's really having the last
laugh here's the truth about some
lesser-known characters in the batman
it's hard to watch the batman and not
realize that john tuturo's carmine
falcone is a major player in gotham but
at the same time his presence is so
shadowy and his backstory is so complex
that you might not realize how
thoroughly he has influenced this city
in decline the falcone character has
been in orbit around batman for some
time even if he wasn't introduced until
the late 80s long after characters like
joker and the penguin had been
established tom wilkinson made for a
menacing falcone in batman begins and
john doman fleshed out the mobster
stereotype quite a bit on the tv series
gotham but tuturo's falcone is a
different beast from the first scenes of
the batman you can see the newspaper
clippings on the wall celebrating the
arrest of salvatore moroni moroni was
once falcone's chief rival and his
arrest opened the city for falcone's
ascension up the ladder of organized
crime the crime lord has his fingers in
many pies but also owns the iceberg
lounge and its club within the club the
mob hangout 44 below this is where
selena kyle's mother maria once worked
and selena has been a regular face there
since she was a child and is now
employed there as carmine later
confesses in a moment of weakness he
killed maria and if he'd had his way he
would have killed selena too then
there's the wayne family carmine was
once shot in the chest and showed up on
the doorstep to wayne manor where thomas
wayne saved his life a young bruce
hiding in the shadows of a stairwell
witnessed the entire incident it is
moments like this that made bruce grow
up thinking his father was a great noble
man whose senseless death needs to be
avenged as carmine is all too willing to
tell an adult bruce wayne however thomas
got his hands dirty too leading to the
death of a newspaper reporter
the front door at the iceberg lounge is
manned by two intimidating if somewhat
dim henchmen serving the penguin and
ultimately falcone the twins as they are
called throughout the film are played by
max and charlie carver from mtv's teen
wolf in an early scene of the batman the
dark knight shows up at the door and
says no i am and when they don't let him
in he uses his fists to remind them in a
later scene echoing the moment bruce
wayne shows up and asks the same
question they allow him in oblivious to
the symmetry on one hand they might just
be low-level bouncers with the gimmicky
bonus of being twin brothers on the
other perhaps they could be gotham super
villains in the making in the comics
tweedledee and twiddle dumb are two
gangsters supervillains whose battles
against batman date all the way back to
1943
much longer than falcone one is a good
fighter the other a good thinker they
are actually cousins who just so happen
to look alike and so diver tweed and his
cousin dumpfree lean into their not so
complimentary nicknames as well as
embracing their similar appearances to
confuse enemies in some incarnations
over the years tweedledee and tweedledum
have been criminal masterminds content
to plot out elaborate crimes and let
their henchmen handle the execution in
other tales they themselves are henchmen
of someone like the joker or the mad
hatter so could these twins be henchmen
for the penguin who seems to be making
his own power play in gotham's
underworld could future films have
robert pattinson's batman squaring off
against tweedledee and tweedle dumb such
thoughts make us curiouser and curiouser
determined to change gotham through more
straightforward means bella real feels a
lot like aaron eckhart's harvey dent in
the dark knight she's running for office
she's eager for a new day and she's
determined to win also like dent she's
oblivious to the daytime activities of
the batman you really could be doing
more for this city
your family has a history of
philanthropy but as far as i can tell
you're not doing anything robert
pattinson's batman doesn't seem too
eager to play politics but that changes
when the two come crashing together in
the film's final act as water floods
into the arena where they're situated
real is urged to flee but she chooses
instead to try and help and is nearly
assassinated in the process this much
seems clear she's won a newfound respect
from bruce wayne that will likely carry
forward into a sequel so where does the
character go from here perhaps as a
political ally to bruce perhaps as a
transformative figure in gotham we can
only hope that unlike dent she stays on
the right side of the lot
although she's barely glimpsed the
presence of selena kyle's friend is felt
throughout much of the film she's the
other woman in the incriminating photo
with the recently murdered mayor
mitchell it is her visage that sicks
batman like a watchdog on the scent of
the penguin when selena kyle overhears
annika's name mentioned she's the one
who hurries to tell her friend that the
heat is on in the process revealing
herself to batman as the catwoman but
she may be more than just a friend in an
interview shortly before the film's
release zoe kravitz claimed that
hercelina kyle is bisexual in the batman
and has an intimate relationship with
annika she told pedestrian that's
definitely the way i interpreted that
they had some kind of romantic
relationship
director matt reeves however seems to
respectfully disagree he told the same
outlet i don't think we meant to go
directly in that way but you can
interpret it that way for sure she has
an intimacy with that character and it's
a tremendous and deep caring for that
character more so than a sexual thing
but there was meant to be quite an
intimate relationship between them
regardless the story machinations
continue when batman catches selena in
an attempt to steal back annika's
passport in a desperate attempt to help
her leave the country but the writing is
on the wall and annika eventually turns
up dead so is annika anything more than
a mere plot device like many characters
in the batman her name doesn't seem to
appear in any batman stories ever almost
certainly she's a new character created
by reeves and co-writer peter craig as
such anika means more than you might
realize for a few additional reasons
first she symbolizes reeves and craig's
preference for creating a credible
detective tale rather than a fan
servicing movie filled with googlable
names secondly she represents a fate
that seems all too common in gotham used
spent then tossed in a trash can by men
of wealth and influence annika got
caught in the cogs of gotham's elite and
was mangled in the process
supposedly barry kyogin was cast in the
batman as officer stanley merkel in the
comics merkel has a fairly short career
as james gordon's partner before
eventually meeting his demise at the
hands of the hangman as for kyogen's
actual role in the movie there's some
pretty strong indications that the
casting news we all heard was a lie or a
joke although it's not confirmed in the
film itself it's pretty clear that
kyogen's cackling arkham neighbor to the
riddler is the joker if the batman lands
a sequel there's a strong possibility
we'll be seeing more of kyogen's
character whatever his name may be it
seems too easy it's never easy with the
joker check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about the batman are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]